Mario Torrey.
Atlanta based.
- Mhm.
- What part of Atlanta?
- Decatur.
Decatur.
Oh.
Are you safe
everywhere in Decatur?
- Yeah.
- OK.
I don't like how you
thought about it.
At my own house.
My house is the
most dangerous spot.
Why do you say your house
is the most dangerous spot?
My kids and the dog.
It's horribly unsafe.
That's kind of the worst--
that's the worst of both words.
- Unsafe.
- What kind of dog do you have?
- Doberman.
- I've got a doberman.
- Get the--
I got a dobie!
Are you serious?
- Shut the front door.
The best breed of
dogs you can buy.
But they'll kill you.
You see?
This is a real comic--
I didn't even
know you had one.
I'll stop the interview.
You got a doberman?
Yeah!
I got a doberman.
Look, if we weren't here, I'd
scroll through pictures, man.
That's me and Roxie when
she first came home.
Right!
[interposing voices]
Aw, look at Dobo when we was--
So you got a boy?
Got a boy.
Do you feel like
he-- has he adapted
your personality in your house?
- No.
- He's scared [bleep] of me.
- Really?
Well, you [inaudible].
I have to threaten him.
It's your voice.
- Yeah.
- Sit down.
- No, it's deeper than that.
Sit down.
Sit your ass down.
[laughter]
You gotta-- yeah.
What about your girl?
My fiancee, man.
Just got engaged.
- [applause]
- Yeah.
Congratulations.
She's-- she's in
the service, man.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
So it's very
organized at my house.
OK.
Yeah, I got a--
you know, it's army,
a dog, three kids.
Oh, you got--
[inaudible] you
walking on the line.
Huh?
Walking on the straight line.
I'm telling you.
So comedy is an outlet.
Is it safe to say that?
- What?
- An outlet.
Oh my god, I be waiting to
leave the house [bleep].
It's like, you just
don't understand.
But, you know, that's
what keeps me going.
You know, it's a motivation.
- OK.
You've got a family
that depends on you.
So I keep going, man.
I love that, man.
You know, I like the fact
that you dig into your life.
Is anything off limits?
No, no, no.
I think it's over, man.
Reality is a funny--
[inaudible] basically dig into
who you are, then why do it?
Pretty much.
- Right.
Exactly.
- And you're doing it, man.
You're figuring it out.
Brother, it's time for you to
get to the next level, man.
Walk on that stage and
do what you do best.
- Let's go.
- I'll see you later, man.